boris johnson dijo ante el parlamento
ucraniano que ucrania volverá a ser
libre y ganará esta guerra johnson como
lo mencionas es el primer líder
internacional en dirigirse al parlamento
ucraniano desde que empezó la invasión
rusa a ese país dijo además de celebrar
y conmemorar también la gallardía y la
valentía no solamente del pueblo
ucraniano sino de las fuerzas militares
y reiteró una vez más que rusia está
cometiendo crímenes de guerra crímenes
de lesa humanidad como los que el mundo
la humanidad ha presenciado en lucha y
en otras regiones de ucrania y dijo que
el reino unido hará todo lo posible para
que rusia rinda cuentas ante el mundo
ante los tribunales internacionales
también hizo un paralelo entre el
parlamento británico en tiempos de la
segunda guerra mundial y lo que está
viviendo en este momento el parlamento
ucraniano y citando a winston churchill
el héroe de la segunda guerra mundial
dijo este es el mejor momento de ucrania
un capítulo épico de su historia al que
será recordado y contado por
generaciones venideras luisa yo son
también detalló ante los parlamentarios
un nuevo paquete de ayuda de qué se
trata
se trata de más ayuda militar 300
millones de libras esterlinas unos 376
millones de dólares para entre otros un
sistema de radares bloqueadores de gps
dispositivos de visión nocturna y más de
una docena de vehículos especializados
en proteger a funcionarios civiles esto
por solicitud expresa del gobierno
ucraniano y también que pueden ser
utilizados para la evacuación de civiles
cuando así se requiera